we're told that the radius of a sphere
can be measured using the formula r is
equal to the cube root of 3 times v
divided by 4 pi where v is equal to the
volume that's interesting normally you
have it expressed the other way volume
as a function
of radius here they have radius as a
function of volume
if the radius of a sphere is 6 inches so
they're giving us the radius they're
saying it's 6 inches so they're giving
us that right there
what is its volume so we have six inches
everything's in inches is equal to
the cube root is equal to the cube root
of three times the volume that's what we
need to solve for divided by four pi a
good first step to get rid of this cube
root is take but take the cube of both
sides or raise both sides of this
equation to the third power
so you had 6 inches you raise it to the
third power you have the cube root of 3v
over 4 pi raise it to the third power
and so the left hand side of this
equation becomes what 6 times 6 is 36 36
times 6 is 180
plus 36 is 216.
so you have 216 and you had 6 inches
here now that you're cubing it would
actually now become 216 cubic inches or
inches cubed is equal to
is equal to the if you take the 3v
divided by 4 pi the cube root
essentially take it to the 1 3 power and
then take that to the third power they
unwind each other and so this just
becomes 3v
over 4 pi
now to solve for volume we can just
multiply both sides of this equation
times
the the the inverse of its coefficient
times 4 pi
over 3
times let me scroll up times 4 pi
over 3. let me make sure you can see
what i'm writing and the whole reason
why multiplying by 4 pi over 3 so that
cancels out with the 3 over 4 pi
and you have your 4 pi cancels out with
a 4 pi
and then you have your 3 canceling out
with the 3 and then you have your volume
is going to be equal to 4 pi times 216
over 3.
so you have we could write it this way
216
216
times 4 pi
times 4 pi
over three
and we could simplify this 216 the
digits add up to two plus one plus six
is nine so it will be divisible by three
that's a fast way to test whether
something is divisible by three so let's
see what it is 3 goes into 216.
3 goes into 216. 3 goes into 21 7 times
7 times 3 is 21.
bring down the 6. you have no remainder
so bring down the 6. 3 goes into 6 2
times 2 times 3 is 6
no remainder so it's 72
so 216 divided by 3 is 72 so it's 72
times 4 pi is equal to the volume it's
going to be cubic inches so 4 times 72
4 times 70
is
280 and then you have 4 times 2 which is
8. so it'll be 288
pi
cubic inches that's our volume and we're
done